>>> VERY GOOD MORNING TO VIEWERS
HERE IN THE UNITED STATES AND
AROUND THE WORLD, IT'S TUESDAY,
MAY 25th.
HAPPENING NOW, SECRETARY OF
STATE ANTONY BLINKEN EMERGING
FROM A MEETING WITH BENJAMIN
NETANYAHU.
THIS IS DAY ONE OF THE THREE-DAY
MIDDLE EAST TOUR TO SHORE UP THE
CEASEFIRE ISRAEL AND HAMAS.
>> LEFT MORE THAN 250 PEOPLE
DEAD THE PEOPLE OF GAZA ARE
BEGINNING THE LONG, PAINFUL
PROCESS OF REBUILDING.
LET'S GET RIGHT TO CNN'S HADAS
GOLD LIVE IN JERUSALEM THIS
MORNING.
THESE MEETINGS BETWEEN SECRETARY
BLINKEN AND THE PRIME MINISTER
VERY IMPORTANT, HADAS.
>> Reporter: YEAH.
WE JUST HEARD FROM BOTH THE
SECRETARY OF STATE AND THE
ISRAELI PRIME MINISTER MAKING
STATEMENTS AFTER MEETING FOR
MORE THAN AN HOUR.
THE ISRAELI PRIME MINISTER
THANKING THE SECRETARY OF STATE
FOR THE U.S. SUPPORT OF ISRAEL'S
RIGHT TO DEFEND ITSELF,
MENTIONING THAT THE U.S. HAS
SUPPORTED HELPING ISRAEL
REPLENISH ITS IRON DOME MISSILE
DEFENSE SYSTEM WHICH HELPS
INTERCEPT ROCKETS LAUNCHED BY
MILITANTS.
HE WARNED IF HAMAS BREAKS THE
CALM THAT EXIST RIGHT NOW THE
ISRAELI RESPONSE WILL BE VERY
POWERFUL.
NOW, SECRETARY OF STATE BLINKEN
FOR HIS PART ALSO SUPPORTING THE
U.S.'S RIGHT -- ISRAEL'S RIGHT
TO DEFEND ITSELF.
BUT HE DID SPEAK ABOUT THE NEED
TO REDUCE TENSIONS AND MAINTAIN
THE CEASEFIRE.
HE ALSO SPOKE AT LENGTH ABOUT
THE NEED TO HELP THE PEOPLE OF
GAZA WITH HUMANITARIAN AID TO
HELP THE PEOPLE THERE REBUILD
AFTER ALL OF THAT DESTRUCTION.
HE DID MAKE AN ANNOUNCEMENT THE
U.S. WILL MAKE A SIGNIFICANT
CONTRIBUTIONS TO REBUILDING
GAZA.
HE SAID THERE WILL BE MORE
DETAILS ON THAT LATER TODAY.
HE ALSO SPOKE ABOUT THE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT THIS AID FLOWING
INTO GAZA DOES NOT END UP IN THE
HANDS OF HAMAS.
THEY WILL SOMEHOW BENEFIT FROM
IT.
THERE'S A BIG CONCERN AMONGST
THE INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY THAT
THIS AID WILL END UP IN THE HAND
OF HAMAS HELPING THEM REBUILD
THEIR TUNNELS OR ROCKETS
ARSENAL.
WHAT IS NOTABLE ABOUT WHAT WE
HEARD FROM THE SECRETARY OF
STATE IS WHILE THERE WAS TALK
ABOUT PEACE AND CALM, THERE WAS
NOT NECESSARILY SPECIFIC TALK
ABOUT SOME SORT OF LONGER TERM
PEACE DEAL, PEACE SOLUTION OR
TWO-STATE SOLUTION JUST YET.
THIS IS THE CLOSEST THE
SECRETARY CAME TO MAKING THAT
SORT OF PRONOUNCEMENT.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> PRIME MINISTER, I HAD A
CHANCE TO DISCUSS OTHER STEPS
THAT NEEDED TO BE TAKEN BY
LEADERS ON BOTH SIDES TO SET A
BETTER COURSE FOR THEIR SHARED
FUTURE.
AS PRESIDENT BIDEN SAID, WE
BELIEVE THAT PALESTINIANS AND
ISRAELIS EQUALLY DESERVE TO LIVE
SAFELY AND SECURELY, TO ENJOY
EQUAL MEASURES OF FREEDOM,
OPPORTUNITY AND DEMOCRACY, TO BE
TREATED WITH DIGNITY.
>> Reporter: AND THE SECRETARY
OF STATE WILL NOW MEET WITH THE
ISRAELI FOREIGN MINISTER AND THE
DEFENSE MINISTER AND LATER TODAY
HE WILL HEAD OVER TO MEET THE
PALESTINIAN AUTHORITY PRESIDENT
AND THE PALESTINIAN'S PRIME
MINISTER.
JOHN?
>> HADAS GOLD IN JERUSALEM.
THANK YOU.
>>> JOINING US NOW CNN CHIEF
NATIONAL AFFAIRS CORRESPONDENT
JEFF ZELENY AND CNN
CONGRESSIONAL CORRESPONDENT
LAUREN FOX AS WELL.
SO THIS CEASEFIRE RIGHT NOW, YOU
GUYS, IT'S HOLDING.
BIDEN IS VERY MUCH CLAIMING
CREDIT IT SEEMS FOR HIS
INTERACTIONS WITH BENJAMIN
NETANYAHU, DOES HE GET CREATE?
>> I THINK HE DESERVES A MEASURE
OF CREATE BECAUSE HE IS THE U.S.
PRESIDENT AT THIS MOMENT AT THIS
TIME.
SO HE ENGAGED SIX TIMES OVER 11
DAYS IN PHONE CALLS WITH PRIME
MINISTER NETANYAHU.
THEY'VE HAD A VERY LONG
RELATIONSHIP.
SOME 40 YEARS.
>> UPS AND DOWNS.
>> NOT ALWAYS POSITIVE, BUT
CERTAINLY MORE UP THAN FORMER
PRESIDENT BARACK OBAMA.
WE REMEMBER THAT VERY ROCKY
RELATIONSHIP.
LOOK, I THINK HE GETS CREDIT FOR
BEING IN PLACE AND NEGOTIATING
THIS CEASEFIRE PRESIDING OVER
IT.
LARGELY BECAUSE THE INTERVENTION
OF EGYPT AS WELL.
BUT, THE MIDDLE EAST WAS NEVER
GOING TO BE AT THE FULL KRIM OF
HIS FOREIGN POLICY.
HE DIDN'T WANT TO FALL INTO THIS
INTRACTABLE SITUATION.
THERE'S NO TALK OF A LONGER TERM
PEACE PROCESS.
SO, HE GETS CREDIT BECAUSE HE
WAS THERE.
AND IF IT HOLDS, I MEAN, THAT'S
A VERY GOOD THING BUT HE DID NOT
INSTIGATE THIS BECAUSE HE IS JOE
BIDEN.
>> NO, THAT'S RIGHT.
THIS IS A TOUGH ISSUE.
IT'S NOT ONE THAT ANY PRESIDEN